non-minimalists
how does one become a hoarder looking
for tips
step one horde
how might your life be better with a
horde yeah
okay uh how does one become a hoarder
what starts the process
is it nature is it nurture so here's my
pithy answer for you letting go
is not something you do it's something
you stop doing and so if that's
if that's true i mean you stop clinging
well then hoarding is means you start
doing something
i know sometimes it's we hear
advice from you know self-improvement
gurus or whomever and
and it's always about doing something
uh taking action of course action is an
important step and
and but when we take action first
without an understanding we often take
actions that move us
in the wrong direction letting go is not
something you do it's not an
action it is merely the the stop
the stopping of of the clinging how do
we do that well it's only
through understanding through immersion
through exposure
to the benefits of living with less and
so if the op
the opposite of that then is not being
exposed to the benefits of living with
less
how did i become a hoarder is the only
question i can answer here
and it's because i didn't understand
what enough
was how does one become a hoarder when
they think
they are not enough tweet that podcast
sean
so my bet the answer it's an oldie but a
goodie clutter is the physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
us
so yeah there's something much deeper
going on
so how does one become a hoarder what
starts the process i mean these
questions
are simple questions but there are very
deep and difficult answers and i think
with each quarter is going to be a
different answer
yeah but i think the commonality is that
there is something much deeper going on
and that that clutter is yes the
physical manifestation of whatever that
is that's going on inside someone
it's yeah it's uh it's i wish
you know there was there was something
where you'd be like well here's what it
is you had trauma in your life so now
you're hoarder
and like and maybe that's true but it's
like it's so universal
right that yes we have all had trauma
sure
undoubtedly even someone who grew up as
idyllic as
bex my wife she grew up on a farm in
minnesota
with middle class parents a dad's an
attorney a stay-at-home mom
her parents still married yes still
married man
and married parents privilege right but
still there's always even in those
scenarios there may not be this
deep-seated trauma you know her first
memory isn't of her father
extinguishing a cigarette on her mother
like mine is
but the the the traumas still exist
nonetheless
and she while she may not be as
predisposed to become a hoarder she
certainly could there are plenty of
people who grew up in
quote unquote normal or seemingly normal
circumstances
who develop some sort of disorder up to
and including
and maybe even extending beyond a
hoarding disorder